the Joe Rogan experience yeah I mean
we're gonna get to a point where
everybody can listen in on everybody
that's what I think I think we're only a
couple decades away from that I think
right now it's like content or you know
service providers have the possibility
to tap it into you maybe you know all
these different government groups knows
how to tap into your phones and tap into
your TV and tap it in the camera that's
on your laptop but I think it's gonna
come a matter time but that's the the
intrusion and privacy is gonna be the
bottleneck to future technology and
we're gonna get to some virtual reality
environment where it is so titanically
bizarre and so incredibly realistic that
whatever the [ __ ] happens in the regular
world is going to lose its significance
it's gonna slowly lose significance to
the point where we're going to accept
that one of the ways to overcome some of
these technological hurdles is to
completely dissolve all boundaries
between all people and information
meaning you're gonna be able to look at
anybody doing anything anytime and
they're gonna be able to look at you and
that's going to be the new reality of
human beings and this will be after
we've accepted virtual reality so once
we accept virtual reality regular life
is gonna be so mundane because you're
gonna be able to create artificial
environments like Avatar world like
you're flying through 2001 at Space
Odyssey
you're hanging out with the chimps
you're gonna have haptic suits on to
give you feedback it's gonna be tied in
to your central nervous system it's
gonna recreate smells and feels and
that's all gonna happen it's not a
matter of whether it's gonna happen it's
a matter of when is it gonna happen I
think when that does happen the big
bottleneck is going to be privacy and I
think people are going to just like
they're doing now with constantly
putting up things on social media
constantly showing pictures of their
kids and constantly giving updates on
everywhere you go and tagging all these
things with geo tags I think that in the
future we are going to just accept that
no one has any privacy and kids today
are more likely to accept it than we
were and our kids are going to be more
likely to accept it than their kids and
it's going to keep going on and on and
on and three four generations it's going
to be life life is going to be no
privacy like if we were all living in
like a big brother-type house
it's [ __ ] no privacy right there's
cameras everywhere those people
willingly do it how long before
everybody willingly does it it's a
matter of time right now it's it sounds
impossible because we grew up valuing
privacy I need my alone time I know
anybody paying attention what I do but
once human things are so incredibly
valuable that once life changes around
us and we know for a fact this is
inexorable it's not going back and let's
Yellowstone blows we get hit by an
asteroid this is life now we're just
gonna accept it
it's gonna go on to the next thing and
you're gonna deal with people looking at
you naked all the time
lol because you don't care cuz you're in
the Avatar dimension riding a [ __ ]
dragon over a volcano you're gonna be
living in a world that's so much more
fantastic than the real world there's
someone looking at your [ __ ] in the
real world you're like go ahead look who
cares you're basically saying that we're
putting ourselves in those little pods
and matrix yes you're saying that we're
willingly climbing in eventually to
these little pods of goo and and and
powering the whole Machine Age yes
because we're just gonna plug in I think
we're gonna be sandy otic I think we're
going to become part machine I think
yeah we're kind of like an act like one
organism with many many parts yeah I
think is that okay you don't have to
you're alive right now
you're alive it you're alive in a
beautiful time you're alive in the
transition between when you were young
and there was no internet to now you'd
be an adult where there's internet this
is the most amazing time ever we're
lucky we're lucky we're the most lucky
because we've experienced both we've
experienced I mean when I was a kid we
didn't have [ __ ] answering machines
no I know right you just called and hope
they're wrong yeah and if they were at
home you never found them even you
opened that door to your house you were
a ghost you just guide be there to trust
you you you were where you said to work
you just went places you do whatever you
want you know another the last Wild Ones
that's what we are we are the last were
the last of the disconnected you know we
were disconnected and then we became
connected in the 1990s though that's a
totally new experience for human beings
and we experienced both parts we were
the last humans to
spirits no internet internet no one else
will ever experience that the only way
they'll experience that is if they don't
have internet but the world has Internet
you know what I want to get back to what
you said how long is the electricity
down if we're attacked on the
infrastructure that's what I want to
know what we were talking about the
Internet yeah look that's another that's
an issue too oh that's all they're gonna
blow em people take us out too which is
just as scary and probably easier to
accomplish that's what I want to know
about like how long is the recovery time
because I do feel like Putin sitting
back there like well I think what
they're really worried about other than
Putin is solar flares they think solar
flares have the real potential to take
out the entire power grid that that's
that's entirely possible
and live life as we know it oh that too
yeah yeah for sure
that's only one thing Yellowstone is the
big one oh that was like a STONER moment
we all just stop do you know about the
the caldera volcano and Yellowstone you
know I do that's the big one I do I know
everybody should be fair I was worried
about that although I know it's bulging
mm-hmm yeah I think the northwest part
is bulging well it's just constantly
having earthquakes they've had thousands
of earthquakes every year for the last
five or six years thousands there are
thousands and a month sometimes that to
me is not worth worrying about cuz
there's nothing we can do nothing that
is like that you might as well just the
what I said they wanna they want to dig
a hole no they want to drill a home let
some of the gas out well Wow
I applaud their you know yeah you want
to Lance's it and push some of the lava
out what's crazy is is that that's
happened to human civilization like many
times over the course of history giant
volcanoes blown up and killed meteor
yeah
bunch of that [ __ ] happened to ya I'll
be loving life cuz I'm small I think
only the small thing survive right
thanks
they said about the what hit the Yucatan
is that we used to be like a mole like
human beings they'd if you trace the
evolution of the human being if you
believe in that nonsense today if you go
all the way back we were like a mole
we're some kind of a mole that was the
yeah literally 65 million years ago
human beings are farthest mammal
ancestor is some sort of a mole that
survived like a little big hit yeah like
yeah yeah and cuz all the upper
predators get wiped out so then they can
thrive because there's nothing to eat
them and they live in a ground so that
these things can live underground in
future underground and when things are
joined in Mars but I think we're just
gonna go underground we are gonna go to
Mars too though some idiots it's a poor
Fox goodness no thank you no thank you
pass why do people want to do that
because we can you're done exactly and
you can come back and have pie yeah it's
dumb yeah and then you have to bring
water or have to go get it and melt it
down but you're there okay you're on
Mars let's just say we're on Mars what
do we do
we're just Tara crying crying stop
working rock yeah I mean I just don't
see the life there well I think people
want to be pioneers and I think it's
entirely possible that you're gonna wind
up going with some really crazy people -
yeah right he wants to be a pioneer that
isolated yeah crazy pants right
[Applause]